hello there reject nation I'm Greg Alva
I'm John Humphrey we're gonna watch from
hissy how Godzilla king of the monsters
should have ended was told with
YouTube's algorithm to say it words like
family-friendly in your video
oh so family-friendly we're rated G you
might say mu for Greg family friendly
friendly families children love us hey
there goes a murderer
a family friend family friendly murderer
mm-hmm-hmm like a Zac Efron in that
Bundy movie Oh string bikini model and a
family-friendly designer brand let's do
this
[Music]
good boy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that would have been cool
[Music]
just imagine
guess so yeah it's just like this is
probably was gonna happen to me if I
charged into battle
now they even got the credit stylist
done his e really well done I read all
this hey everyone thanks so much for
watching as always we hope you enjoyed
it and extra super slippery towards his
friends over at nied's gaming for being
our guest guide you on this whatever you
like hilarious gaming content with a
more cinematic touch then go give me the
sub if you haven't already ok thank you
for watching that's all for now we'll
see you next time Wow hmm no Batman at
all single BM this house should have
been a video feels the most family guy
like in spirit I've ever felt in regards
to I've been like touches that feel a
little bit Seth MacFarlane like but
especially with go to your go to your
echo tier half of the monsters in the
kaiju university now you just make some
fouls it's go doula Villa Rodin Roedean
Billy chocolate yeah when they were
bantering with each other that would
have been honestly that would have been
a sweet move though if Godzilla was like
blasting his way over I think I would
have died in the theater that would have
your excitement yeah awesome that would
have been the exact kind of silliness I
would I would hope for they bring up a
great point about him versing King Kong
though yes can do because he does that
in the movie yeah a nuclear explosion if
Godzilla is able to do that
maybe the writers were working on
Godzilla versus Kong
I like how how would he win and then
they just solved it for us of what he
shoot Godzilla can't do any of them
maybe that's it maybe they laid this
Easter egg in so that in the next movie
they're like oh it came back one thing
this made me do was think a lot about
Godzilla vs Kong because you think about
them my punching each other and stuff
but Godzilla has a couple of extra
powers he's got a range man he might not
have the arm length he got the range
weapon he might not be able to
Liman advantages physical speaking wise
and we can move around like an ape
Godzilla can just like shoot at him if
he wants to you know and explode on him
if he wants to or have wacom with his
tail wagon with his tail yeah he's got a
heck of a guy he's got reach what he's
got he's definitely has say he's got
weapons at his disposal they live within
him I do think with the amount of times
they reference King Kong that would have
been a pretty sweet ending if he did say
King Kong a merger but even if that was
like their post-credit scene just like
it ever be as the monsters an encounter
like where am i what the hell's going on
I'm mad about it we're just escaping
from chains in New York City landed over
here these other guys don't like you
guys that's a great point they made in
their opening though like let him know
we're honest I feel like Godzilla's
pretty smart enough to figure out that
these guys who kind of blew up my home
huh yeah was about that whole
interaction they had in the last movie
maybe they solved their misunderstanding
back then and Godzilla remembered and
was like oh yeah it's these humans when
I recognized a couple of those guys okay
it is funny as the alpha frequency
pointing was where they killed you know
Tywin Lannister I'll never remember that
actor's name Charles dance sorry for
some reason ever like yeah good for you
John it's because I've heard his name
know me so many times so many names so
oh you got the memory of a Falcon
totally and the wingspan
to match yeah when they killed Charles
Lannister that moment is funny in this
how it should have ended bit but would
they have had enough control over Mothra
in order to accomplish such a kill all
three of them would have died all three
of them exactly so I know it shouldn't
have been in that way and plus if it
ended there it would have been so early
in the movie yeah that's a short they
would have been a really short movie and
colin trevorrow should direct that
poor Ken Watanabe I did kind of feel
that way I was so excited that he was in
these movies and then especially once we
got to king of the monsters it was kind
of clear like oh you're just I guess
here to lend credibility or something
he's here to lend exposition job yeah
and to be Japanese well then yeah but
she's the one who goes in goes Udo he's
the only one I thought the editing of
that bit was really funny got some great
points how they all stood could have
taken out Godzilla but I love the cut
when you know you should just let me die
let me die take us damages in a full
suit that's really good that's great
this was really funny how it should have
ended one of the most consistent YouTube
channels to have ever existed thank you
guys for putting this together
good you laugh at a movie in an
intentional way when it's filled with so
much unintentional laughter throughout
oh yeah I liked it I had a lot of fun
subscribe to how should it I mean you
know what I say if you haven't already
subscribe really if you haven't already
click on it about yeah haven't already
Oh John don't mock people with
disabilities I'm sorry Greg didn't mean
to mock anybody especially you I have
sexual disabilities sorry no they
expected your speech hey before we wrap
this video up let's give a page from the
day shout out to a person named Omar
young about four weeks ago you and I
were exchanging a lot of messages back
and forth you were telling me about how
you and your wife had startup business
videography photography as well I feel
like I crossed the line here know what
you do and I started asking questions
about your relationships you're telling
me all these exciting things about what
you're setting out to accomplish and I
was like yeah but I want to get to know
you a little bit better and I asked two
questions and my last message has the
relationship strengthened since tying
the knot and I also said what's your
wife's name if I can ask of course it's
been four weeks and I haven't heard back
from you so I wanted to say I'm sorry
for invading your personal space I know
you opened up to me about some stuff
clearly I crossed the line because you
know if I knew your wife's name and I
said her name it would destroy the
marriage destroy a marriage because she
would suddenly turn all of her
sire that she has left in your marriage
towards me just me uttering her name
would make her though
oh my god it's Greg I need to be with
everything would have fallen apart more
importantly you would have unpledged so
hmm I would be awkward I get it if you
want to just come at me with a different
message you want to swear at me that's
fine too or you could lie make up an
answer make up and make up a different
name mmm-hmm I'm let's say you're you're
Mexican wife is named Tiffany or Britney
or as Murrell de it's a cool name now
dude the joke is that thing not Mexican
name oh sorry I don't know where that
name originates from but that's Mexican
no sorry Craig
I've met many Mexican guys and white
guys named Craig so yeah that works all
right
omona silence for Craig
[Laughter]